hello
in this video we'll talk about a
genetically encoded calcium sensor which
is known as g camp
and we'll talk about its application in
biomedical research
gcamp which is a genetically encoded
calcium sensor was first
reported in 2001 by junishi nakai in
this video we'll talk about what is
gcamp
how gcam works an advantage and
disadvantages of using gcamp in
neurobiology research
from 2001 the neurobiology research has
really changed a lot gcam
is a big discovery in neuroscience and
let me tell you why
so gcamp is kind of like a gfp molecule
which is attached with a calmodulin
residue and calmodyline is a protein
that can binds to calcium
also there is a m13 peptide that is
binding
to the gcamp moiety
now when calcium binds to these g camp
then there is a conformational change
generally
gcamp in calcium unbound state does not
fluoresce
because
the chromophore moieties are protonated
now when calcium binds there is a
conformational change and the
fluorescence is now
shown
notice the m13 helix is now in a
different location
and this results in the conformational
change and fluorescein of the gf
gfp molecule now
so gcamp can fruitfully report the
calcium fluctuations inside the neuron
and calcium fluctuations in the neuron
can work like a proxy of neuronal
activity
so gcam can can reproducibly report the
neuronal activity but what's the big
deal about it because neuronal activity
can be recorded using patch clamp
technique and that has been reported
several decades ago
so what we have achieved so far using g
chem what's the added advantage
and that can be understood if we try to
look at the applications of gcam
first of all activity from several
neurons can simultaneously be recorded
using gcam based approach
so under the fluorescence microscopy in
a field of view let's say there are 100
neurons and all of their activity can be
recorded simultaneously which was not
possible using a patch clamp recording
in bachelor recording one neuron has to
be recorded at a time and that's the
added advantage
now using g camp and a combination of
two photon microscopy scientists are
able to record neuronal activities from
behaving animals such as this particular
mouse they can really drill a hole on
its skull and can record the
record the activity if the mouse
expresses g camp in its
particular brain region in this example
we can see how the mouse brain region is
fluorescing over time and because they
are marked by gcamp
another advantage of gcamp
is we can utilize these approach
combined with two photon microscopy to
image neurons which are located in a
deeper location in the brain
now using
conventional patch clamp technique it
might not be so easy to get access to
those deeper neurons
but light can access these neurons
easily right so obviously the
fluorescence light that is coming from
those deeper layers can be recorded
using a two photon microscope
now let's see how the data obtained from
gcam recording can be analyzed
generally scientists record the delta f
by f value and plot it over time
so what is delta f by f so it is
relative change of fluorescence over
baseline fluorescence
so delta f is a quantity which says
fluorescence at time t minus
fluorescence at time 0
and baseline fluorescence is given by f0
so what is these parameters so you can
see
if this is the activity profile of g
camp the ft is a particular time point
where we have recorded the fluorescence
and f0 is basically the baseline
fluorescence actually after recording
the fluorescence over time scientists
can get several time frames like these
so here we can see
the fluorescence intensity as a function
of time
so fluorescence intensities are shown in
each frame which are like 2.5
milliseconds apart
and we can see at
time f equal to 10
the fluorescence intensity reach its
peak so it's kind of like a peak
activity time and again it falls down to
near baseline so overall we get any time
point and compare it with the baseline
fluorescence and thereby we generate
these delta f by f curve
now the biggest advantage is we can
draw roi or region of interest around
specific neurons from a particular live
imaging
movie and
we can calculate the fluorescence over
time and that would give us an idea
about how the neurons are
firing over time period so you here we
can see at least the this particular um
neuron which is marked by
the orange traces has three peaks where
the violet traces has much more peaks so
these kind of informations that means
special temporal dynamics of a neuronal
activity can be
captured using these approach
moreover
we can also get an idea about the
overall circuit activity on the right
hand side you can see the circuit is
functioning in a synchronous manner that
means all the neurons in these circuits
are firing in a synchronous fashion
whereas in the left side we can see the
neurons in these circuit are functioning
or firing at an asynchronous way so they
are not firing all together these kind
of informations can be obtained using
gcam based approach and live imaging
approach
but what are the disadvantages of this
kind of
live imaging
so if we record
and
image the calcium activity from the same
neuron
one thing might be very clear
that the g camp
is a proxy readout for neuronal activity
it does not really resolve the neuronal
activity in time so much
so let's say this is a fast spiking
neuron and it's burst at a very fast
rate
and that can be seen from this image
now if we record
in a whole cell configuration the
voltage fluctuation shows there are like
multiple peak of activity burst of
activity
but that is not nicely resolved in this
calcium imaging that means temporal
resolution is slightly low in case of
gcam
now in order to circumvent these kind of
problems scientists are now improving
gcamp they are making gcamp
f which is which can possibly capture
these kind of fast dynamics so there are
also many different type of g cams they
have also generated r cams which is in a
rfp range
so overall in this video we understand
how gcamp is a very useful tool for the
neuroscientists
i hope this video was useful if you like
this video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe
you can support my channel on patreon if
you're an indian viewer you can support
me via beam upi your small contribution
means a lot for me my courses are
present in academy which is india's
biggest learning platform you can
subscribe to this course by using my
code ap 10 and you will get a 10
discount
thanks for listening